خبر عاجل ورد قبل قليل ان طواقم الاسعاف
تمكنت من انتشال عدد من الشهداء في
المدينه بعد انسحاب جزئي لالي الجيش
الاسرائيلي معنا الان من خانيونس مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر اسماعيل ما
التفاصيل حول قدره طواقم الاسعاف من
انتشال جثامين عقب انسحاب جزئي واين تركزت
هذه
الانسحابات الذي حدث بان انسحابات جزئيه
تمت من وسط معسكر خان يونس للاجئين حيث ان
اليات الاحتلال تحركت اكثر الى الغرب حيث
الحاجز الذي اقامته في اول يوم للعمليه
البريه التي وصلت فيه الى معسكر خان يونس
وهناك اعاده تموضع لهذه الاليات في ذلك
المكان بعد ان تحدثت مصادر بالامس ان ايضا
ذلك المكان كانت قد انسحبت منه اليات
الاحتلال بمعنى ان اليات الاحتلال تقوم
باعمال مناوره بين الحين والاخر باتجاه
الشرق والغرب بالمعسكر خان يونس الانسحاب
الجزئي صباح هذا اليوم من وسط ال المعسكر
باتجاه اقصى غرب معسكر خان يونس وهذا ادى
الى وصول الناس الى تلك المناطق التي
انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال وبالفعل قام
هؤلاء المواطنون بانتشال جسامين الشهداء
ونقلها عبر عربات الى مستشفى ناصر في حين
ان طواقم الاسعاف لا يمكن الدخول الى ت
الى تلك المنطقه بسبب القيود التي تفرضها
قوات الاحتلال وعمليه اطلاق النار لل
التجريبيه حين والخر من قبل اليات
الاحتلال التي تتموضع وتنتشر في اجزاء
مختلفه من مخيم خانيونس خاصه بالاجزاء
الغربيه منها اداد الشهداء التي الذين تم
انتشالهم حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم لم لم يتم التعرف على احصائيه محدده
حول عمليه العدد الذي تم وصوله الى مستشفى
ناصر خاصه ان عمليه الانتال ما ما زالت
جاريه من قبل المواطنين ويتم نقل هؤلاء
الشهداء عبر عربات فيما ان الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني بالامس قال بانه تعامل مع 12
شهيدا داخل اروقه مستشفى الام
الذي ايضا يتعرض لحصار اسرائيلي من قبل
اليات الاحتلال اضافه انه تعمل مع عدد من
الاصابات في محيط المستشفى لكن هذا الحديث
لا يعني ان هناك عددا نهائيا لاعداد
الشهداء خاصه في ظل احاديث كثيره من قبل
شهود عيان ومواطنين بان قوات الاحتلال
ارتكبت مجازر بشعه في منطقه معسكر خانيونس
وكذلك منطقه حي الامل وهناك اداد من
الشهداء ما زالت جثامينهم ملقاه على الارض
في اكثر من شارع وفي اكثر من طريق في
المناطق الغربيه لمحافظه خان يونس ما يعني
ان اداد الشهداء مرشحه الى الازدياد خاصه
مع ساعات النهار التي يتنقل فيها
المواطنون باتجاه تلك المناطق وتلك
الشوارع في ظل تقييد ايضا الحركه من قبل
اليات الاحتلال نتحدث بان اليات الاحتلال
قامت
بانسحاب بشكل جزئي للمناطق الغربيه وهذا
دفع المواطنين لتحرك في تلك المناطق لكن
وسط خطوره بالغه مع استمرار اطلاق النار
بين الحين والاخر من قبل اليات الاحتلال
تجاه المواطنين من خانيونس مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل ابو عمر شكرا جزيلا لك